à faire condamner les
responsables de ces gestes
qualifiés, de crimes de guer
d'unipipipipipipipipipipipipipi,
que les tombes et les fosses
coununes ont été découvertes.
Des centaines de croix,
certaines portant des
des dates, parsèment
les environs.
(hurlement des sirènes)
Des militaires spécialisés
en médecine légale ont été
avec la tâche d'exhumer
les cadavres qui y sont
enterrés, certains depuis aussi
longtemps que mars dernier.
Des analyses ADN,
des autopsies seront effectuées
sur les dépouilles afin
de savoir qui a été tué et
comment. Selon les autoritililià
plus de 400 corps.
"C'est un véritable charnier,
rempli de personnes assassinées,
dit le président uDes enfants, ,
des civils, des militaires,
certains torturés même."
Volodymyr Zelensky évoquerereree
et appelle la mmmmunauté
internationale à réagir.enenenes
de guerre,dmdmet le chef
de la diplomatie américaine.
ces crimes doivent être punis."
Un message porté aussi
par la ministre canadienne
et par l'Union européenne.
Les exhumations devraient
se poursuivre enco
plusieurs jours à Izioum.
Libérés de l'occ
cette semaine, les habitants
de la ville auront besoin
de temps pour se libérer aussi
de leurs cauchemars. Ici Lise V,
Radio-Canada, Montréa